من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ضيفنا مرحبا بك يعني كما
افاد مراسلنا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
يستعرض بنفسه وقد ركب تشالنجر
وتجول بها اهميه وصول هذه المركبات
العسكريه الدبابات والمدرعات الان الى
اوكرانيا
محمد هذه تعكس المرحله القادمه او صوره
الحرب القادمه دبابات يعني قوه صدم يعني
حركيه يعني هجوم عكسي اذا صح التعبير
اليوم هذه الدبابات اذا ما نظمت من ضمن
منظومه قتاليه وادخلت في المنظومه
العسكريه استعدادا للمرحله القادمه هي
دبابات حديثه ستؤثر فعلا على ارض المعركه
نتحدث عن التشالنجر هل سياتي معها قذائف
الايرانيوم المنظم والتي تحدث عنه الرئيس
بوتين ام القذائف العاديه هذه المرحله
بالاضافه الى الدبابات محمد هناك العربات
المدرعه هذه تستكمل منظومه الهجوم اذا صح
التعبير للمرحله القادمه في هذا الوقت
عميد الياس حنا تتحدث عن موسكو عن اختبار
ناجح لصاروخ كروز فرط صوتي من طراز موسكيت
قراءتك في الزمان والمكان لاجراء هذا
الاختبار
مريم عندما نتحدث اليوم عن الحرب
الاوكرانيه يجب ان ننظر من المنظار
الاوراسي يعني اليوم زياره الرئيس الصيني
الرئيس بوتين روسيه تطل على الغرب وتطل
على الشرق وفي بحر في بحر اليابان امر مهم
جدا هي رساله لليابان
فلنتذكر ايضا ان الرئيس تشيك كان يزور
موسكو والرئيس ورئيس الوزراء الياباني كان
يزور اوكرانيا فاذا هذه المرحله مرحله
جديده يجب ان ننظر اليها من منظار كبير
وهي دوله بحريه في تلك المنطقه وهي تسيطر
منذ عام 45 على جزر الكوريين ايلاند
الخاصه والتابعه لليابان وهي اجرت مناورات
عديده في بحر اليابان فاذا من ضمن هذا
المنظار يجب ان ننظر الى الصوره الكبرى
الجيو السياسيه
طيب فيما يتعلق لو عدنا ميدانيا مثلا الى
المناطق التي تدور فيها
المعارك هنالك تغريدات
جاءت من جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه
البريطانيه تتحدث عن سير المعارك لم تصف
يعني حركه القوات الروسيه في مثلا بانها
تقدم وانها مجرد محاولات ليس الا الى اي
مدى يعني تسيطر القوات الروسيه على
المعركه في هذه المناطق ودقه تنشره او
ينشره جهاز الاستخبارات البريطاني
محمد في افديكا يبدو من خلال نتائج
المعركه ومحصول المعركه ان قسم منر بدا
يشاركوا في افديكا ولكن اليوم افديفكا قد
تكون مخمود الثانيه يعني اليوم عندما توزع
القوى هذه القوى تستنزف ومؤخرا اخلت
القوات الاوكرانيه او الحكومه الاوكرانيه
اغلب الناس من ابدلكا وكانها ترتقب هذه
المرحله اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
المنظار الروسي انها متصله بمخموت انها
عمليه اشغال القوات الاوكرانيه على جبهه
طويله استنزافها وتثبيتها في مكان ما
لمنعها من التحضير والذهاب الى ما كان في
بدايه اللقاء حول موضوع الدبابات والتحضير
للهجوم العكسي في المرحله القادمه شكرا
جزيلا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي